thank you to Nord VPN for supporting PBS
well it's 2020 now be honest how many of
you decided to kick off the new decade
by making a resolution to get into shape
does this sound familiar you head into
your local gym the bodybuilders are
pumped the club music's bumping the
smoothie station is blended and a sales
rep presents you with a menu of contract
option yo you ready to get jacked sweet
you can sign up for a whole year for
$600 or on a month-to-month basis for
$58 a month or pay per visit for $10 a
day so which one should I choose the new
you plans on working out three times a
week so the cost per visit for each plan
shakes out like this we're not including
those extra startup fees since most of
the time those only exist so they can be
waived to make you feel like you're
getting a bargain from a purely
mathematical standpoint the annual
contract makes the most sense and maybe
by locking yourself in you'll be more
likely to stick to your resolution
psychologists call this strategy pre
commitment when your present self tried
to control the behavior of your future
self but making obligations your future
self can't get out of social scientists
John Elster cited the story of Odysseus
and the sirens as a classic example of
pre-commitment the sirens were creatures
of Greek mythology whose beautiful songs
lured sailors and rental ships on the
rocks
Odysseus wanted to hear the siren songs
so he instructed his men to tie him to
the mast in other words he didn't trust
his future self to resist temptation so
he took steps to limit his own freedom
in the same way gym members tie
themselves to a financial commitment to
prevent their future selves from
succumbing to the temptation of not
working out
Oh essentially pre-commitment is an
admission of weakness so does it work
sometimes yes setting up an automatic
withdrawal on your paycheck into an
investment account is a good way of pre
committing to a savings plan and buying
healthy food at the grocery store does
pre commit you to cooking at home rather
than eating out but when it comes to gym
memberships the results are a little
less optimistic according to survey have
5,000 American gym members 82 percent or
less than once a week and 22% stop going
completely after six months so much for
pre commitment in light of those odds
maybe it's best to go with the monthly
contract sure it costs a bit more but at
least my future self betrays me I can
drop out and cut my losses right oh
maybe not another study on the habits of
gym goers or non gym goers found that
members who subscribe to a 70 dollar
monthly program ended up using it only
four point three times per month even
though the gyms had a $10 per visit
option they were essentially paying $17
per visit and here's where it gets weird
the whole point of these monthly plans
is that you could cancel whenever you
want but people in the monthly plans
we're actually 17% more likely than
annual members to keep their
subscriptions going after 12 months even
if they weren't using them future self
what the heck is wrong with you the
answer is that the monthly subscribers
were on an auto renewal program which
simply charged their credit cards every
month without needing explicit
permission from the customer because
it's a passive transaction these auto
renewals don't cause much negative
utility what economists call the
emotional pain of losing money if those
people had to actually hand over 70
bucks in cash on the first of every
month a lot more of them probably would
have canceled their memberships auto
renewals or evergreen clauses are pretty
ubiquitous these days and they are
convenient
imagine having to manually renew every
regular service you use but some
companies are less than
right about it hiding the cause behind
free trials or making canceling an over
complicated process you often won't even
be notified when your subscription is
renewed because they want you to forget
about them gym memberships are
especially tough to cancel because it
feels like admitting defeat and many
gyms charge re-sign up fees that make
members just keep paying in the hopes
that maybe they'll start using it again
it sounds like a broken system but this
is actually how it's designed to
function see running a gym is actually
really expensive high utility bills big
spaces filled with tons of fancy
equipment a large staff of trained
professionals in order to pay for all
this they have to sign up way more
people than the facility can actually
serve major fitness chains commonly
recruit between five to ten thousand
members per location which have max
capacities of just three to five hundred
people if just 5 percent of their
members showed up at the same time
they'd have to start turning people away
so despite all those motivational
posters and slogans they're counting on
the vast majority of their members to
rarely or never use the service they're
paying for the silver lining is that if
you happen to be one of the small
minority who actually uses your gym
regularly well you're making out like a
bandit three or four dollars a visit is
an incredible steal only made possible
by all those other resolution breakers
who are subsidizing your wellness now of
course we're not saying that you
shouldn't try to get into shape regular
exercise is one of the best things you
can do for your body mind and pocketbook
since many expensive medical problems
can be prevented with a healthy
lifestyle but there are cheaper ways to
kick-start it for instance you can buy a
nice pair of running shoes or a bicycle
and chart a course through your
neighborhood home fitness equipment like
weights bands even machines can get
pretty pricey but at least once you own
them you don't have to keep paying every
month there are also lots of inexpensive
apps and online courses and free YouTube
videos that can help get you started
many fitness experts will say the most
important thing is and what equipment
you use or how many calories you burn in
a day but by
way to make exercise a lifetime habit so
how do you do that don't look at us for
a financial show but we can say that
making big financial commitments doesn't
seem to work if you already exercise
three times a week joining a gym can be
a great bargain but if you're just
starting out don't think you can extort
your future self into exercising with
the threat of a dead weight loss
turns out our future selves are pretty
crafty at wriggling out of pre
commitments especially when the pain of
losing money is no match for the pinyon
I'm gonna feel in my legs tomorrow and
that's our two cents we'd like to thank
Nord VPN for supporting PBS imagine VPN
as a secure encrypted tunnel for online
traffic to flow nobody can see through
the tunnel and get their hands on your
internet data Nord VPN allows you to use
public Wi-Fi in coffee shops or hotels
or anywhere else that you're on someone
else's network that way you can access
personal and work accounts on the road
or simply keep your browsing history to
yourself they don't log your activity
while you're online they've got
thousands of servers in 60 countries and
24/7 customer support to learn more
about Nord VPN just check out the link
in the description so tell us what is
your favorite or most effective fitness
product you've ever bought for yourself
tell us in the comments
you